[Music]
hey you guys time for tombs of terror my
book review show
now this book i picked completely at
random uh again this was one that was
recommended on my kindle unlimited so if
you have kindle unlimited you can
actually read this one for free um i
just i don't know i i saw the title and
the and the i didn't even read the
description at all
which which i'll get into in a minute i
didn't read the description at all i was
just like uh it's called dark corner and
i was like oh that sounds like an
intriguing title why not so uh so i put
it on the list and uh started reading it
now what i did not know and at first i i
will admit that i was kind of like
bummed out about it i was like oh it's a
vampire novel so know that it you know
it's a vampire novel uh i'm not i like
vampire stuff i do but it's not my
favorite monster especially if i'm gonna
be reading
reading about it um i don't mind vampire
movies so much it's not usually
something i seek out much anymore
because i feel like i've seen
all the good ones but you know i'm
always willing to have my mind changed
about it but as far as novels go i
haven't really read any vampire stuff
like in a long time it's just not a
monster it's just kind of like zombies i
don't really want to read a zombie thing
it's like i'm kind of sick of zombie
movies um you know so books i usually
like haunted house stuff or
you know stuff that's more psychological
or stuff that's not classifiable like
the monster is not classifiable so i was
kind of like bummed out when i
discovered or realized that this was a
vampire novel but that said it actually
turned out to be a pretty entertaining
read now this book was written by
brandon massey and it's uh older than i
originally thought i think it came out
back in 2005
and as i mentioned it's called dark
corner now
what ends up happening with this now
like i said i'm gonna say right here
this was um pretty good
i didn't love it but at no point did i
be like oh [ __ ] i don't even want to
finish this you know what i mean so it
was like kind of in the middle like
three star type of [ __ ] to me
i think the thing that bothered me the
most about it well i don't even know i
don't know if it bothered me about it or
because some things about it like look
essentially and i'm going to tell you
this right now essentially
this is
salem's lot
but
filtered through at least the first part
of it filtered through blacula and to be
honest
uh brandon massey for sure like was
homaging blacula because one of the
characters in it not one of the vampires
but one of the vampires um kind of half
human servants is named mama walde uh
which if you've never seen blacula or
scream blacula's green which you
absolutely should because they're both
amazing movies uh i love both of them
um that was actually that's actually
blacula's real name is mama walde and so
there is a component in this that's very
similar like the vampire's backstory the
main vampire's backstory is very similar
to the backstory in blacula the setup of
the novel um this narrative structure of
the novel is almost
and the plot beats of the novel i'm
gonna say i haven't read salem's lot in
a long time
but
it's very very similar to salem's lot
now you could say that salem's lot is
very very similar to the original bram
circus dracula obviously and stephen
king has said that too he's like you
know i wanted to do my own modern modern
riff on dracula so
this is kind of i don't know so i guess
you could say but it is very very
similar to salem's lot so know that
going in but that said um you know i
like salem's a lot i like blacula so you
want to combine those two things fine
with me i found it a perfectly
entertaining novel not great but
you know i had a pretty good time with
it
so the story behind this um there's a
guy the main character is named david
hunter now
his dad richard who he was sort of like
estranged from he didn't really know
that much about his dad who's kind of
like famous like uh kind of famous in
literary circles and things like that
it's kind of very well known he
apparently dies in a boating accident
and david returns to uh the town where
his dad was living which is a very very
small town called mason's corner in
mississippi now it's called dark corner
because the um
the uh population of the town is
uh 90 black now originally
uh there was a house in the town called
jubilee which like i said is very much
like salem's lot like marsden house or
whatever it was called uh there's
there's a plantation house called
jubilee and there's a backstory with uh
mason the guy you know mr mason i can't
remember what his first name was but
mason who was like a slave owner like a
plantation owner
owned the house back in the old days
and he was actually killed him and his
family were killed during a slave
uprising
and
interestingly this slave uprising ties
in with david hunter and with his
ancestor
and it also ties in with the vampires
like why the vampires end up in this
town as well
so david moves back to his dad's old
house because
he feels as though uh he missed out on
something not knowing his dad growing up
because as i said his dad kind of
took off and like left his mom when he
was very young so he didn't really know
him
so he wants to go back and kind of see
what he can see so he goes back and
moves into the house he's from atlanta i
think he'd been living in atlanta so he
moves back to this little town in
mississippi and he's not planning to
stay there forever he just wants to stay
there for maybe like a year or something
and uh see what's going on with it
now as soon as he gets there he meets uh
the really nice
uh neighbors like across the street
who's like an older gentleman and uh his
wife and the older gentleman is like a
retired professor and he's like a
historian so he's kind of like the
source of all the exposition about all
the history that's going to take place
and i liked his character a lot he was a
lovely person but i did have a problem
with like the dialogue because it seemed
like
he talked very much like a professor
would talk but not really you know what
i'm saying it's i kind of feel like he
talked like somebody
who was trying to make somebody sound
like a professor would talk do you know
what i mean yeah he kind of sounded like
that it didn't really sound like uh his
dialogue didn't sound super
realistic to me but like i said he was
kind of like this character who was
there to tell all about the history of
the town
um david also meets this young woman
named nia
and the two of them start a relationship
with one another like i said very much
like salem's lot where it's this guy
he's a writer or whatever although i
don't david isn't a writer i think he's
like a web designer or something like
that he's something where he works at
home so he beats this young woman named
nia they start to fall in love with one
another
and also uh in a parallel uh kind of
thing that's going on
there's this vampire named kyle
and he has a vampire mother named lisha
and
they and she's kind of like
raised him because apparently like
vampires exist in this universe
but they like to kind of keep a low
profile and they don't kill people
anymore they basically just drink blood
from like blood banks or whatever
and they have some there's not a lot of
them but they have a thing set up where
they don't have to kill people anymore
and um lisha
is kind of like however old she is she's
like really really ancient and she
basically says you know that we don't do
that savage vampire [ __ ] anymore we like
kill humans we're just trying to like
co-exist or like just keep on the down
low and like not
interact with them and not hurt them
we're just gonna kind of do our thing
over here and not worry about it anymore
uh so she's raised her son kyle who is
now older you know older and he's a
vampire as well
but in a parallel story to david and his
father
kyle um
[Music]
wants to find his own father now his own
father was this very very powerful
vampire named diallo
who was actually made into a vampire by
lisha back that she was like um he was
like a warrior in africa and then he was
brought to the us during the slave trade
and he was one of the ones that kind of
like revolted against a lot of the slave
masters and stuff like that so he became
very very powerful
and there was at some point in
um dark corner or mason's corner
there was kind of like this big
confrontation between diallo and some of
the other people he had made into
vampires and uh david hunter's ancestor
so they kind of fought and they actually
ended up putting diallo into like a
stasis or like a sleep and he's actually
like in a cave underneath
jubilee the plantation house which has
been abandoned for a very long time
so you have these two kind of forces
coming together like david comes back
into the town trying to figure out like
what is the deal with his dad and then
when he gets there he starts finding all
these little weird things about you know
kind of the history of the town and how
his ancestors are involved in it and
then you have kyle the vampire who has
decided he doesn't want any more of this
nicey nice vampire thing he wants to
actually kind of he doesn't really get
like that until he comes back and like
gets in with his dad
but he's not really down with this whole
uh kind of we just want to stay away
from humans type of thing he wants power
so he goes to the little town and uh
essentially tries to resurrect like his
dad diallo and as that happens he
becomes more uh kind of more evil more
like diallo is and diallo uh once he's
awakened and is back to his full
strength again uh they basically him and
kyle start to
make um
just trying to start making like a
vampire army out of like all the people
in the town so they have you know these
whole like big packs of like vampire
dogs essentially and they have all of
these kind of humans because there's
kind of a difference between
the vampire vampires like the powerful
vampires and ones that they just bit and
then they just made them
they're kind of vampires too but they're
like not as powerful there's like lower
level
but the fact that this the vampire
plague can sort of spread either through
the people or through the dogs means
that this little town like starts to
pretty much like build up into like
vampire army territory like pretty quick
and so as that starts happening
obviously people at first don't really
want to believe it but then you know
david and nia and you know all the other
gang like all the good guys like
including like the sheriff and
everything
they kind of start to think well there's
like some weird [ __ ] going on like
people start going missing and then
eventually when they see particular
things they have to come to terms with
the fact that these are actual vampires
and you know the whole town is going to
be overrun if we don't do something
about it so it's basically comes down to
it just builds up and builds up to a
point where it's like the townsfolk
or the remaining townsfolk against this
ever growing like vampire menace
or sort of thing so it's a pretty
straightforward uh vampire story as i
said the plot beats to it are very very
similar to salem's lot uh so if you like
salem's lot and you're not
concerned that this is
essentially like i said a kind of a riff
on salem's lot just filtered through
a different sensibility uh you know
filtered through blacula through the
black experience through uh slave trade
and stuff like that like i said which
was kind of i mean the the backstory of
blacula in the movies was kind of the
same thing like similar to that like had
having to do the slave trade and
everything so it has that kind of uh
thing to it too honestly like i said
it's this was like a pretty decent book
it's was quite long
um i didn't really realize that when i
was reading it it's it's like 550 pages
or something like that um probably
didn't need to be that long but it
didn't really seem to drag or anything
um mostly it kind of jumped around from
like a lot for a lot of different
characters like uh in the town and stuff
which actually kind of kept it
sort of fresh and kept it moving
honestly i i quite enjoyed it like i
said i didn't love it um but
because i guess because it wasn't
a super original idea and like i said
it's not really the book's fault because
that i'm not super into
vampires but i'm not super into vampire
novels and i went into this not
realizing that it was a vampire novel
because as i said i did not read the
blurb like at all and i'm not even
really sure
i'm not even really sure if the blurb
says vampire in it um it does say undead
but
yeah i guess you could like for i mean
you know undead that usually means
vampire or zombie but um because i'm
reading the blurb right now and i was
saying does it even say vampire in the
blurb so even if i'd read the blurb like
would i even know what was going on but
you know what i mean i don't know but um
yeah so it might have been just that i'm
not like super crazy about vampire stuff
but that said like for a vampire novel
this was actually a pretty good like
entertaining one as i said i did have an
issue with like a couple of the
characters whose
dialogue didn't sound
all that realistic to me i mean most of
them most of them did like most of it
sounded pretty naturalistic but the one
character and he was a good character
too was like kind of the professor guy
he very much sounded like
i don't know if anybody would talk like
that in real life but i could be wrong
about that um and as i said he seemed to
be the guy that like knew everything and
there was also kind of like another
character
um who was a psychic and
she kind of knew some stuff and could
like fill in some other blanks type of
thing too um so there was that so you
could tell that there was a couple
characters that were put in there
specifically for the purpose of like
filling in information for our
protagonists and there's nothing wrong
with that you got to do that somehow but
i think it was like a little bit too
obvious maybe i don't know that's maybe
why
why i thought that but other than that
like i said it's it's pretty
entertaining if if you want to read
something that's like i said it's long
but it doesn't it didn't really feel all
that long to me and it's just basically
like a small town
small mississippi town versus vampires
you know it's actually really quite good
in that and some of the action scenes
are really good it keep it like i said
it moves along at a good clip but you
know if salem's lot made splacula sounds
like something you want to read then
this is the book for you because that is
almost exactly what it is um but yeah
you know like i said decent read not my
favorite but um you know as i said i'm
not super into vampires but if you are
into vampires have a read and tell me
what you thought about it or if you've
read it or if you've read some of
brandon massey's other stuff because i
know he wrote one called thunderland
that a lot of people uh talk really good
about and i'll probably get around to
that one as well um but yeah so let me
know if you've read it in the comments
and that will do it for this tomes of
terror i will see you guys on the next
one
bye